Marvel's runaways as being run off the
air on Monday November 18th Hulu
announced our runaways will end after
its fast approaching third season set to
hit the disney own streaming platform on
December 13th deadline confirmed the
news further noting that fans will get
closure with runaways season 3 which is
said to bring the narrative to a quote
natural close and neatly wrap up the
story that follows six teenage heroes
whose parents belong to a coalition of
supervillains so what really happens a
push Marvel TV and Hulu to ax the show
well you can blame the numbers for that
it's always the numbers sure fans adored
the show and critics were kind to it but
Runaways was actually performing worse
and his fellow Marvel superhero series
you know the ones that were all canceled
at Netflix between late 2018 and early
2019 in a March 2019 data reports
Business Insider provided analytics from
jump shots that indicated roughly
640,000 people watched the first season
of Runaways in his first week on Hulu in
November 2017 with eight hundred and
twenty five thousand people tuning into
the second season during his first week
in December 2018 that may sound like a
lot of people but it isn't even the
bumped up viewership number for Marvel's
Runaways season two was only about half
the amount of people who watched the
least viewed Marvel show on Netflix
the highly criticized Iron Fist which
poured in 1.6 million viewers in the
first week after dropping its second
season and surprisingly runaways
couldn't hold a candle to the most
watched Netflix Marvel show at the time
daredevil with five point eight million
week one viewers for season two
no dad good huh thank the 8-ball well
something went in Business Insider noted
that despite rising interest from season
1 to season 2 of Marvel's runaways
neither instalments ever reached a
million viewer mark in the first week
this could be as a Outlet stated down to
the climbing viewership for all of
Marvel streaming series viewership
trends that were headed in the wrong
direction for the superhero series on
Netflix followed by the rapid-fire
cancellations of every single Marvel
Netflix show may have pushed more casual
viewers away from Runaways possibly
because they feared the show would soon
suffer the same fate as daredevil and
the like additionally it isn't destroyed
Runaways wasn't interesting or exciting
impressive reviews and the loyal fanbase
proved the opposite but the diverting
strategies that Netflix and Hulu
implemented with their respective Marvel
properties may have been a downfall of
the combined collection of superhero
shows Marvel's runaways included despite
the show's low ratings Hulu's still
renewed Runaways for a third season
though it seems a streamer may have
ordered those final 10 episodes with the
knowledge that they'd be the last ones
people would ever watch on that note
it's been clear for quite some time now
that Marvel television it's experiencing
major shakeups the creation of Disney's
streaming platform Disney Plus meant
that the mouse house which owns Marvel
Studios and thus Marvel television
division would be creating new original
series based on its gallery of
superheroes all to be produced by Marvel
Studios led by Marvel Entertainment chic
creative officer Kevin Feige rather than
Marvel television headed up by executive
vice president Jeff Loeb in an apparent
effort to consolidate its various
properties and bring them to one place
Marvel previously cleared house and
Netflix by pulling the plug on daredevil
Iron Fist Luke Cage Jessica Jones and
The Punisher with those shows to the
Netflix fans would surely have to turn
elsewhere to get their superhero series
fix and where better to look than the
massive streamer that will be home to a
ton of marble shows good Marvel Studios
executives have chatted with the TV
division and the folks are Hulu about
bringing Runaways to an end to further
clear the path for Disney plusses Marvel
Universe to thrive it's not out of the
realm of reality we're all that's left
hey hey it's okay all right we're gonna
figure it out we have each other what
also likely contributed to Marvel's
runaways getting axed it's a fact that
Jeff Loeb was reportedly lines up to
leave Marvel television The Hollywood
Reporter claims at Loeb who has served
as executive vp of Marvel TV since 2010
will make a formal announcement of his
departure before the end of the month at
some point ahead of Thanksgiving Day on
Thursday November 28th with runaways on
its way out there are only a handful of
low produced Marvel Series in existence
agents of shield which will end with a
sub coming 7th season who lose horror
themed Marvel show hellström and for
adult oriented animated series it seems
evident the Marvel Studios is taking
over the television side of things from
well the actual television division of
the company Marvel's Runaways isn't the
only show to have become a casualty amid
all this change and as sadly may not be
the last he is hoping that what Marvel
Studios has planned witnessed Disney
Plus series will be worth all the hard
sake of watching so many shows get
snapped away and that the few remaining
Marvel TV bug projects live to see at
least a few seasons check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos buy your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]